hello welcome to the lobby Jesus Christ
my voice acting skills breaking down in
front of you
hello welcome to lobby GameSpot's weekly
hangout every Tuesday 2:00 p.m. Pacific
right here on twitch.tv Ford / GameSpot
and on gamespot comm if you're watching
it live how you doing folks
I'm here with no GameSpot staff members
nope we have mine usurped supplanted
thrown out it's a coup that's a way
better one Matthew Mercer from critical
role hey doing good good about yourself
I'm doing fantastic Maurice are a high
critical role that's oh yeah how are you
doing double dip in there I know we're
gonna use all in Quad dipping in a
second
now we roll deep we came in the old quad
dip yeah sex aids number one Episode one
you learned it here folks it's like a
Sugar Ray lyric quad dip that'll bring
him back in there oh yeah that's a
reference thank you so much for coming
in we had a lot of fun around this table
about an hour ago
playing Dungeons & Dragons yeah how'd
you like it I loved it I D and E is one
of it we were talking just before we're
gonna live about how you had that friend
who had Nintendo you sort of kept close
to ya Andy is one of those things if you
have a good like Dungeon Master it's
such a great like things yeah you want
to keep them around yeah exactly
good have like I knew some people in
London when I lived there for water we
got out and we kind of dipped in a
little bit since I moved here did a
little bit with Giant Bomb comer our
sister website nice but a but haven't
really like gotten into a property in a
couple years until today again there you
go thank you very much yeah welcome for
more fantastic I say you you also have
like the patron saint of DMZ
I don't why it's the sounds of fish
beasts being torn apart I have a lot of
it's been a lot of time alone when I was
a kid okay
you gotta find ways to pass the time
like making sounds of fish heads being
pulled apart yeah no it's great and I I
think more so now it's a good survival
technique for younger adolescents right
you know social environments not so much
now I was younger a lot of kids like oh
you're good ninja master he can stay
around no you didn't really have that
reaction as a kid but uh yeah it's been
really cool to watch this whole tabletop
renaissance past years and and so many
more people
one getting back into the game or two
realizing what they were missing when
they were growing up and trying it out
for the first time in finding out it's
just a lot of fun yeah for sure over the
over the next hour we're gonna talk a
lot about video games stuff but for the
moment I do want to talk about that with
you guys cuz they're like I don't know
the internet stuff mechanism that allows
the sort of smaller pockets of our
society to be seen by way more people
and in doing so those it sort of like
gathers all those people around right
yeah yeah people find their niche yeah
you know to find their their crowd yeah
that doesn't yeah there doesn't seem to
be like little niches anymore there's no
such thing that's kind of it's like you
know previously geographical boundaries
or like close Rabanne geez
disappeared so what's happening with you
guys are critical role obviously on geek
and sundry and that's you've got like a
you know their audience has been
building as well but like your show has
exploded in like a very short period of
time it's been on for about just over a
year just over a year yeah what was that
something you expect it to happen no
we're still kind of holding on for dear
life we you know we've played the game
privately for two years beforehand and
it wasn't our initial idea to turn it
into a show we were asked to take it
online by Felicia with geek and sundry
we were kind of mist about it at first
because when you take something that's
very personal and you can enjoy it in
closed space and then put it in front of
cameras in the Internet you're like
standing in front of a firing squad of
commenters beings target yeah and so we
were initially worried about that
transition and we figured you know give
it a shot if people like it able to do
it for a little bit if doesn't work out
we'll just go back to our game at home
and we found such an amazing community
that continued to grow and grow over
time that and it didn't have a huge
impact on how he played the game and
enjoyed it which is all right I guess
worried so we just kept doing it and
figuring out where it might land and
it's gotten so much bigger than we ever
expected yeah the other sights of this
obviously is that your video game voice
actors as well by trade and when you
like put that in front of like a you
know web producer like video producer
it's like [ __ ] gold
it's like deanzie which basically
involves like putting on accents and
being able to be yeah I thought you did
a pretty great I seriously I walked in
and I you're like yeah I'm not gonna try
and you're not
Irish accent I was like oh [ __ ] there
goes everything I mean we were both in
Ireland a couple of weeks ago yeah yeah
my one gets like well thicker when I go
home sure yeah yeah and then my
girlfriend's like you Americanize your
accent when you're at home I actually
did an American accent for her last
night and it freaked through the [ __ ] at
no stranger danger
so Kinnear that's great we grab her like
40 I was even like yeah honey honey
there's someone at the door so I guess
you brought it then on to geek and
sundry yeah do you think that audience
was already looking for a D&D show or
have you like brought in a lot of people
like hey where's your audience coming
from who are they it started the geek
and sundry audience which were already
it was a phenomenal community of
like-minded geeks and gamers fans love
came in through like will we this
tabletop and so there tabletop
enthusiasts audience to dive into right
there were the ones who kind of started
the inertia and then word of mouth man
can't knock it yeah it's good
tried-and-true old fashioned yeah it
works it started there and then began to
become just kind of this this weird
thing there aren't a lot of I mean there
were a lot of other real play game shows
that were on YouTube and such but do
like live real play you know we're by no
means the first yeah and there were
great shows that I watched for years
beforehand that I thought were great
examples of D&D playing we just happened
to find an audience of people that were
at that time that wanted to see what it
was about and especially with twitch
which is a great format for other gamers
who are on there for illegal engines and
other game types did you come across the
front page on the Thursday and be like
why is there a bunch of people standing
here click on and be like I don't know
what's happening in an hour later be
like oh now I get onions and dragons
know this I never knew it played like
this and people all of a sudden get this
renewed interest and something they
never really thought about or thought
they could understand yeah it's been
really cool to watch that grow so it's
it's this weird organic expansion that's
a you know my favorite comment though is
what the [ __ ] am i watching
what the [ __ ] is this so you're you
actually like converting people like
window shoppers who were just like oh
yeah we've gotten inundated with tweets
now weekly about people who have started
their own D&D game or have decided to
pick up a dungeon master guide and start
dungeon mastering on their own so every
time we see one of those were like one
of us spread the joy yeah so what do you
think is like the special sauce of
critical role that has made it like
expand so quickly I don't know the only
way I can think of zero a lot of shows
that I really like and I think what I
like about the shows that I've watched
in the past like the real roleplay guys
with it's me JP and and that the stuff
that a lot of those folks have done is
it's a group of friends playing a game
if you just take random people and put
them together to run a game sometimes it
can be it's fun but there's something to
be said about people who have built a
rapport over time and and maintain that
feel of just like chilling in the living
room unwatched playing a game and less
performing for the audience and since
we're all naturally kind of you know
bombastic indoor kids that you know talk
to ourselves a lot of the time it's an
easy transition for us and so I think
that is part of the appeal if anything
is the fact that we're all just been
close friends playing this game for a
long time so we have that rapport built
in and I don't know honestly that's the
best I can guess we're still trying to
figure out ourselves we're just glad
people show up every week to watch it it
is hard to say because we're not
consumers right you'd but maybe you can
probably even answer that question but
yeah than us it seems to be the sort of
you know each other's towels like it's
very comfortable yeah we've been doing
this now for three years with each other
so because you know we were playing the
game for about two years when we started
the stream right so we were very
comfortable I think it's also you know
something has to be said about the raw
storytelling element of it because when
the show first got pitched and
introduced the problem was that there
wasn't going to be visually engaging
yeah enough for today's audience it's
like people sitting down talking to each
other right in the reader for hours yeah
even you know even the cast we were like
there's no way there's no way anyone is
gonna want to listen to this
but it kind of harkens back to the old
sitting around a campfire telling an
Illiad kind of feel to it and I think it
shows how important storytelling is
especially in today's medium when you
start stripping away all the VFX and
write all the flash that you see in
modern storytelling today in movies and
whatnot and it still shows that people
still need and want a solid story
especially if you've got a very good
storyteller which which you do have like
there was something when we did the
stream right here today like everything
each of your characters the way you were
like reacting the way you were like
planning attacks and not just the voices
but just like the body language of it
all like in my head when I think about
what we just did like I see the marsh I
see exactly what happened I see that the
big Maelstrom Beast of bones and drugs
it's crazy
do you think it has something that is
well to do it with the ability of people
to consume like different types of media
like like during their day because
twitch is kind of this this platform
that you know like television has always
been you sit in front of a new sort of
engagement on a moment-by-moment basis
sure as this seems like something could
have on in the background that you're
sort of like enjoying while you're
engaging with your day to day life I
mean people were tweeting today saying
I'm on my lunch break yeah I'm just like
spending a couple of minutes or I've got
it like in my tab here yeah it's almost
like like a radio play in ways yeah
exactly and so you know it there's
there's a lot of really cool elements of
watching it's you get to see the
physical expressions and reactions and
looks of surprise and you know the the
maps and the minis and all the fun stuff
that's involved there with the
physicality but you don't need that
either you want people to just listen to
it while they're doing chores or getting
their taxes done and I just reminded
sorry
it's destroyed everyone's but that's
also you know what's cool about this
format is you can't just listen to the
full audio and continue about your day
and have this adventure going on behind
you the whole time and I think it's
something different that the story
anyone who's watching it they're
discovering the story with the players
right now and so when you watch it live
there's stuff
you have in adrenaline that kicks in
when you start seeing us in moments of
peril and I think you wouldn't you know
you don't necessarily get that when it's
a movie or then or a game but I think
when you're watching it live and you
realize that we are experiencing it live
with you it creates almost a more
interactive experience in a weird way or
you feel more presents
probably yeah you feel like you're a
part of the story as it's being created
around you so that makes sense yeah I've
got loads more questions about that sort
of type of stuff and also the sort of
the wider world of voice acting yeah but
first of all I wanted to get your
thoughts on one new story that sort of
happened this week or a game that's
coming out pretty soon actually it's
about two weeks Apple we preview
coverage is sort of dropped for recently
it's a quantum break you guys know
quantum break yeah so remedies next big
game everyone loves on awake everyone
big fans of Max Payne around this office
yeah yeah and this is like a big game
that originally when they were pitching
it was part of sort of Microsoft's wider
you know we're gonna have our television
wing we're gonna have our video games
wing we're gonna sort of cross pollinate
them and why not so they built this
whole television show featuring a bunch
of very recognizable actors and I plays
were under embargo for a lot of a but
yesterday we streamed the first like
chapter of the game essentially about 40
minutes of gameplay followed by a 23
minute long cutscene oh snap yeah like
well produced not like cheapest chips
like it's it's no house of cards but in
the middle is they could you know
somewhere touching themselves full of
like you know dozens of different
characters and side plots and whatnot um
which is the sort of that the latest in
this long legacy of video games trying
to take what happens in you know
interactive art and what happens in in
film or television and sort of merged
the two of them together right yeah um
what do you guys think about that is
like a future for video games because
you guys work on the forefront of games
development would work and you also have
an eye for the theatrical side of it
which people most people in development
don't so what do you think about that I
think I think we're still and we happen
for a while we're in the infancy of
finding what works and what doesn't in
that you know and right now we're still
in that process
kind of throwing things at the wall and
seeing what sticks and I think because
we've had games that have really
elevated the platform from a
storytelling standpoint and blended
those lines so well in recent years
examples being like Last of Us or a lot
of the tell-tale games where they can
really you know maintain an interactive
element throughout where you still feel
invested and involved from an
interactive standpoint but still are
enjoying and are engrossed in the story
in a way where you're you're involved
but still a viewer and it's it's those
are great examples and in my opinion of
that form developing however with a lot
of these innovations and V are now
promising even further immersion in a
variety and and trying to make that
maintain that balance of atmosphere
interactivity without it being too heavy
one way the other I'm excited to see
these examples of games that are that
are make taking risks and trying out new
things and and when I when I heard the
whole the whole theme behind quantum
breaking what they're trying to do with
that I was really excited I'm still
really excited I'm always very curious
to see how that it turn out I'm a guy
who loves cutscenes I didn't skip
anything in middle years so I'm one of
the one of those guys even the truck
know something's gonna happen no it's I
myself am actually very excited about it
I don't know if they'll all work I think
we've had have a lot of David cages
stuff we'll also tried a lot of you know
yeah interesting ideas that often really
hit the way you would hope for but even
so that sense of precedent and is a
great example for other game designers
to then build off of that and make
something that is more fine-tuned
towards what his you know final vision
may be so any hits or failures they're
all helping build towards what will
eventually be the emerging platform of
interactive gaming and really the key
word that you said there was immersion
and I think we're seeing all media go
that way too immersion and like you said
you have to walk the line between not
being like oh this is work you know and
still feeling entertained like you're
being told a story so you never want to
go like you know people give a lot of
[ __ ] to heavy rain right but they did
make a lot of progress --is and sure we
don't need to have to physically turn
every every jar
but it is interesting the way it's going
but we're also seeing that with digital
comics right now on iPads that have
little sound effects or you know little
things with comics we're seeing that
even with twitch I feel like you can
still count that with twitch where the
audience can comment and participate
yeah while they're watching things so I
think anything that's gonna start
merging the two yeah that's that's where
all medium is going in my in my opinion
what do you think when you see like hot
like front of camera recognizable actors
on something like quantum break when you
guys are like you're already in there
like you're part of like videogame
performance right right so like does it
feel like they're sort of coming into
your into your neighborhood and Matt I
mean I'm a big proponent of the best
performer for the job right you should
be what's considered in some cases there
been projects that maybe you've worked
on where they've done the stunt casting
around and they'll bring somebody in
without an audition just because they
like their work in a project sometimes
they're amazing and they knock out of
the park
sometimes you but mostly there are
situations where they'll go a week
recording or so and they'll be like
alright cool we're gonna go ahead and
recast that right um it's a little
private victory for us lesser-known
folks but there are plenty of paper
formers that can do both sides so I you
know I'm and I'm a big fan of a lot of
that work so like if the best perform
for the job steps into the ring go for
it you know there is always that worry
that if if it goes more and more
celebrity talent than those of us who
don't have that kind of you know pool
hmm might be passed over in a lot of
situations for future roles where
honestly in some cases it may not matter
if they're not using the likeness of the
actor performer it's about the
performance not the actual individual
behind it yeah and so it depends on how
the project's being promoted and what
their marketing goals are for it is a
lot of those casting choices are a
marketing choice right we'll get more
marketing money if they've got a name
attached yes I mean you can see that
what quantum break then you know there's
a lot of very recognizable people in
that yeah and you can't fault them for
that yeah I want to see a lot of them so
do you think that there's a difference
cry
though to like what they're doing in
terms of like I don't next to nothing
about performance at all but there seems
to be like there is a more maybe there's
like subtle nuance that exists obviously
in both forms but there when they're
acting in front of camera it's I don't
know I feel like the voice work requires
a lot more energy or verbose Nisour
which might not necessarily transition
well for those individuals whereas you
guys are like comfortable with yeah it's
a it's a different skill set definitely
and when it whether it comes to voice
over behind the mic to performance
capture with facial capture to on-camera
acting each is its own skill set that
you're kind of switching gears into with
on camera everything is very very thrown
away very internalized minimized it's
not about showing your expressions it's
about keeping it all internal and very
subtle you know you have the opportunity
on camera to display emotions through
subtle I've movements and through just
you know reactionary very very minut
expression changes you don't have that
opportunity behind the microphone and
you have to be able to convey those same
subtle shifts and changes with only your
voice and that is why you'll get some
actors who aren't trained classically or
three at reclaim LR theatrically who
then get behind the mic and then this
sounds very stilted right in monotone
because they're used to relying on that
one skillset when they haven't learned
the other conversely you have some voice
actors that move over to on-camera work
and are way too over-the-top right and
so you find performers who have trained
in all those different skill sets know
how to switch those gears and can really
knock out of the park both ways and a
lot of on-camera actors that come over
into performance capture and voice over
and do a great job you'll find are those
that a lot of cases are trained
theatrically on stage because that skill
set lends itself very well both ways
like both projecting yourself and also
having sort of like small mm-hmm tender
moments yeah and knowing how to arrange
and kind of you know meticulously
puppeteer those right would you like as
you know folks you do this
professionally would you like video
games to go down the route of what
quantum break is doing and actually
having that live-action element is that
something that excites you or is that
something that maybe you think actually
detract from the work that you do no I
take it or leave it
yeah I will have to see it I I mean if
all video games start to go that route
then that could be unfortunate
but I mean I I love Dungeons & Dragons
and I also love fallout you know I in
those two things offer they satiate me
in different ways yeah and I think
that's probably what we'll see this
stuff like quantum break I don't think
it's gonna be a replacement I also am a
bit of a sucker for the artistry of
digitally painting environments and and
the the artistry that the CG artists go
into with video games I don't think it's
gonna be Universal though I mean [ __ ]
will still see games like nidhogg come
out which are 8-bit which are is a
phenomenal game it just satiates
different needs yeah yeah and on that
point to a the interactive element of
gaming can only allow so much
live-action pre-filmed content before
it's no longer as interactive as the
driver requires to be called interactive
so they'll always be a line that they
can push to a certain point before you
have to then turn it over and rely on
all the wonderfully talented 3d
animators and riggers and and people
that actually create all these variables
that allow the interactive experience so
I mean it doesn't worry me by any means
I'm curious to see how it's involved and
how it can help elevate the storytelling
platform of games but I don't foresee it
taking over or replacing yeah you know
other elements just just because the
limitations of the the pre-filmed you
know video format yeah otherwise we end
up with a whole new realm of 3d oh yeah
let's get that night wrap 2017
kick-started guys thanks so much for
talking about that if you're watching
this on demand you have any thoughts
yourself about the future of 3do games
coming back let us know what you think
in the comment box below folks I want to
talk to you about your actual jobs
projects things you've worked on how
many voices do you think you've landed
your voice - how many characters owe him
more than me okay how about that I don't
know 100 maybe yeah
between that cartoons and video game is
probably Ivan Ivan counted I have a lot
of voices in this head anyway right out
of recording so
did you start in the animation stuff and
then make your way over the games or did
they sort of go hand-in-hand I actually
started morning games to animation and
and still can't really do commercials
while it's weird if people have
different things they're really good at
everyone friends to do a lot of promo
and commercial I can't book either for
the life of me but I'm really well in
interactive games and you can't sell a
ShamWow real good I think he's too nice
you have too much nice guy voice people
are like fans [ __ ] yeah that's why I
get you know beaten and robbed a lot
what's at what what would people
recognize you from what are you sort of
like most notable oh let's see
notable recent roles I mean overall I've
voiced Leon Kennedy in Resident Evil 6
and the film damnation
I have voiced Alvin in tales of Xillia
kromm and fireman awakening and Rihanna
and the new fates game that just came
out
I have always Macready and fought for
which came on not long ago I have always
iDEN a few other characters in the
Minecraft telltale game the new chapter
coming up soon that I'm really excited
about I mean that's pretty good yeah a
little bit so once again recently I am
Margaret in the persona franchise and in
persona dancing all night long yeah the
best one and then I am a playable
diamond dog soldier in metal gear
phantom pain
I am Fe and Makoto and Oboro
and Fire Emblem fates and Laura are Sade
in trails of cold steel or legends of
hero veterans of heroes trails will see
that's like the longest name alpha plus
on ps4 and Vita yes a bunch of voices
yes yeah what's your favorite voice
you've you've done favorite voice like
favorite character yeah tell you like
all that all the other way
that's such a tough question I like the
weirder characters yeah you know I enjoy
you know the deep performance I actually
really enjoyed doing a lot of stuff from
a Korean fallout 4 because he got to go
into you know a an emotional spectrum
and his story was kind of tragic in a
lot of ways plus it's a fallout fan
anyway I like these recurring from three
which was fun the stupid little pug face
kid of little lamplight how long is a
job like how long was that like that
fallout job how long does that take the
job each sessions about four hours
straight of recording which is in itself
a process and then that character in
particular I think we did close to six
sessions okay
so yeah you're looking at about 24 hours
total of recording for all of his
possible dialogue certain games no
longer associates performance capture
that can be right weeks at a time for a
prolonged project length
I just finished RPG recently called
mascara which is coming out on a
PlayStation Network and PC on Steam it's
a it's a great kind of isometric
beautifully 2d drawn RPG and my
character Cicero I probably recorded
close to 20 session rate that one for
our session because I guess that's the
nature of something like a isometric
role-playing game yeah a lot of dialogue
a lot of characters optional dialogue
this yeah
that's insane but then you know you you
have games that 12 lines you go for it
in a game like a MOBA or like any game I
guess every game has murder in it right
that's now yeah okay combos have you do
your own grunts it's not like a thing oh
yeah audition with those guys believe it
or not it a lot of people can't do it as
your grunt work a lot of you grunt it's
true John I mean we've I think probably
everyone in this room has had to be
brought in to scream or grunt for other
people too yeah that can't grunt a lot
of celebrities I've had to do already
did what are you doing just like not
want a recording of themselves that
they're going
possibly like nope no I'ma be reduced to
this level yeah or conversely they just
they don't know how to do it for what
they want for the game right like
something like screaming like in order
to scream you have to be fairly
uninhibited yes like when you think
about it like screaming you have to
really kind of get ridiculous about it
and so I think some people get
self-conscious to do combat different
types of combat sounds right characters
like for League of Legends
a voice gangplank and Wolf of kinder
than that and similar mean the same sets
of script but you have to make them
sound very unique different they're both
low voiced characters it's about where
you can find the variations and texture
and grab between going or and for the
same thing and be able to keep them
separate enough where you don't hear the
similarity and is it difficult working
with audio engineers who do they have
the language like the do you have a
communication with somebody where they
say oh no I see which is near bro
can you do it this way like the verbage
for trying to explain the two different
types of grunts you did there which are
very different
yeah like director director do you think
are they getting better oh yeah for the
most part 100% for the most part I like
directors who can get me direction in
like one or two world wars yeah if you
like if you're a director who can give
one to word Direction aces you guys have
to be really good at picking up on what
that isn't then yes finding do the same
and you have to do yeah yeah which
honestly is we're about actors getting a
callback for a project yes not just to
see if you're good for the part and I've
narrowed it down but it's also to see
how well you take direction right you
suffer a lot of callbacks they'll still
throw a lot of notes at you not because
they really want to hear a variation but
they want to see how well you can adapt
listen and make those choices and get
where you where they're trying to get
you very quickly because they'll know
when they get you in the booth that
you'll be able to perform and so yeah I
mean it's a good director will know how
to communicate quickly and succinctly
what they want and be able to work with
you the performer to get it out of you
and a lot of directors a lot of my
favorite directors are actors as well so
they have that that communication
already or have gone and taking classes
for Performing Arts and and acting so
they can better understand that language
all right it's been great that's good
they some more success that successful
ones tend to be people who have that
sort of in my opinion yeah that's
excellent
well we've got a bun we've also got
laura bailey and travis willingham a
hanging so i I'm going to be a director
I guess further for some characters who
don't have voices okay okay you may or
may not know all of these characters may
be on the obscure okay like I'm so sorry
in advance but I think you're going to
do great and one of the four of you is
going to get the gig perfect and so
we'll get you guys to do first and then
we'll bring on our other two esteemed
colleagues so the first one I think we
have is Claude speed from Grand Theft
Auto 3 who is the main character from
GTA 3 doesn't speak a word it's the last
character in Grand Theft Auto history
who doesn't speak actually yeah I said
he does and CJ and some guys does so
Claude is yeah he's like a leather
jacket wearing sort of like denim
trousers think he's from the East Coast
I think he's from Liberty City New York
kind of thing that's the that's what the
Laura says yeah yeah I'm so you're at a
disadvantage or maybe in an advantage
hey you don't know me man let's go point
that's good oh I'm going for James
Claude yeah
Derrick that's in there Claude speed oh
look the Claude alright so I just Sabre
engine yeah alright well I guess you
guys I'm gonna have to grab my baseball
bat so I can go meet up some more
hookers you wanna come on over tonight
I gotta bother Jack my back pocket and
got my trusty Louisville Slugger and uh
let's go find some hookers a lot of work
to do
yeah alright like I mean from it from a
serious like auditioning standpoint yeah
he he looks young but he's also got that
kind of toughness to him that little bit
of me like a New Yorker to him sort of a
boys get by me yeah we got stuff to do
tonight we got money to make people to
kill and we got some business to take
care of soon step in the back of the car
if I wanted to be fooling around be like
more of like a little scrunched up face
maybe he said guys come on these pants
are a little tight on me I'm pissed off
it's Friday let's go steal some cars you
think I'm funny that's nice okay let's
go a little bit in a different direction
now I'm gonna go for second artist here
sort of I think I think this individual
went to some sort of university I think
it was as what's the what's the really
good Texas Science University that's on
the East Coast like in my teen years old
yeah he's an MIT graduate surely okay
works in a secret government lab
somewhere in the West Coast he's fought
he's shot a lot of soldiers in the past
he's shot live alien blood crates lakh
crates he's cracked in a lot of crates
his name is Gordon Freeman I've heard
from her okay yes okay
Matthew you wanna go first this long
then bottom voice Gordon Freeman I know
it no pressure
what's Gordon Freeman say I for some
reason I seem having a little bit of a
higher power yeah because he's very you
know he's he's tech-savvy he's worked in
the lab for some time you know but he's
but he's definitely been through the
[ __ ] a little bit manda do some things
is not necessarily proud of but what if
it requires to make sure that those who
can survive the incident Black Mesa I
managed to get through okay yeah yeah
yeah get behind me
one of the very few pictures of his face
actually yeah that's nice counting over
and a crowbar to Marisha see I don't
know for Gordon I kind of always
imagined like a little bit more of
almost like a William H Macy kind of
thing no he's got a little bit of that
kind of easily thing going on but he's
still you know he still doesn't he still
sounds like he can take a punch every
once in a while
you know I'm gonna vote for you on that
these crabs me congratulate romantics
Gordon Freeman I got a couple more for
you too let's go for PlayStation 1
not a lot launch game first six months
it was the face of the PlayStation you
could say actually and we an animal that
people aren't really sure if it's a real
animal or
lots of tribal masks because like
Sonic's the one light with which like no
matter what voice they put on them
people are like chili dog no no it's
yeah Roger is a great job yeah he's
unfortunately under the shadow of this
early sonic cartoons yes it's a real
tough one
yeah so bandicoot's in the same way
where I don't think people really think
about crash talking sure so I never
thought of him talking he's gonna be
like you go first no you didn't I didn't
no you're right you're right you did
like I said he doesn't really use words
though he's got the burgers yeah he's
got the fingerless gloves he's got the
sneakers on he's got the rolled up jeans
God I've never noticed there was
fingerless gloves before he's yeah he's
everything in 90s you know mascot
character wanted to be you wanted to be
cool badass but also kind of chill and
hang buddies you know if he was wearing
a shirt it would a Papa wrote written on
it yeah yeah it's like if we're talking
like Crash Bandicoot when it first came
out voice you know he's gonna be kind of
intense high energy a little zany but
you know wants to be chill with his
buddies drink ecto cooler you know yeah
I would whoa sick ollie when it came out
this what it sounded like
yeah more days I'd like to think they'd
make him a little more serious yeah
stoic like I was gonna say almost died
while a coyote
he's like hello and welcome to character
Crash Bandicoot
he's a gex now apparently yeah crash
aneurysm says the and/or in the twitch
chat okay let's swap it out yes I where
to look at you on Twitter and whatnot uh
you can follow me at Marisha underscore
ray underscore ah someone some [ __ ]
unique enough that you could have got
away with it there's a democratic
politician named Wayne I know there's no
dining or doireann I'm super lucky you
are lucky you guys are minder and you
guys will fight in a parking lot so
great to be raining like matrix
evolutionist I asked like really this is
Spider Man like just that type of heavy
heavy rains at that level you want
medical number in the raindrops yeah
Marisha underscore ray and of course you
can watch me on critical role and then I
actually have a new show that just came
out on geek and sundry called signal
boost yes second episode by itself just
today what about yourself sir you can
find me on twitter as well under at
Matthew Mercer no underscore no
underscore now sorry lucky bastard I
just have SMAC underscore daddy 86 at
hotmail.com some jerk on Smackdown how
dare he you know it's porn sites
exactly yeah is it registered no I god I
still have it on you Jay
yeah I'm any other project so far from
critical uh apartment role just a couple
of the game projects that are coming up
can't talk about yet great announcements
to come hot embargoes indeed thank you
so much appreciate it laura bailey and
travis willingham
Marisha ray and Matthew Mercer they're
popping off don't worry and you come how
you doing good see you again what top of
the mornin see it's great rule I know I
got a green crowbar as well I can't get
really good you were we were watching
from the side yeah half life would
totally sound like Heisenberg come on
you'd do a Gordon Freeman you wanna do
to Gordon Freeman no I'll take the
crowbar away then actually before we get
into those what wonderful voice work
have you lent your daughter Altos oh my
gosh recently anime back in like 2003 my
first big role was Colonel Roy Mustang
and Full Metal Alchemist was one of my
favs and then I've had roles like guile
and Street Fighter and Reggie and
infamous second son and Fred 104 in halo
5 Guardians which came out last year was
in Mad Max escape her scrotus just a
just a ton of really fun stuff I didn't
realize you were scrotus sake that's a
fantastic one the giant horn coming out
of his dick yes true giant horn crotch
yeah it was the best part of that they
didn't do that until they saw the
performance capture and no they
literally put a Styrofoam horn on my on
my cross we have a picture of it really
yeah it really did you couldn't really
thought it they thought I was gonna
affect my my movement had these giant
exhaust pipes coming out of her
shoulders in there like on the wing yeah
so did that and you got a picture of it
oh yeah wonderful frame actually yeah I
can't not for now that that's wonderful
Laura what about yourself what have you
worked on recently recently um recently
halo 5 yeah as Olympia Vale Uncharted 4
which is coming out very soon Gears of
War 4 which was just announced I'm
playing Kate Annette
which is pretty exciting um Street
Fighter chun-li world Warcraft Jaina
Proudmoore
Black Widow and Avengers yeah so much
stuff that's fantastic yeah but we have
some lesser-known
characters maybe some of these which
don't we talk all that often which maybe
you guys can help us write the auditions
process what we're doing for Uranus I
definitely looked like somebody who'll
be able to pay you for your voices I
sure hope so
we are expecting money no any works for
me okay first one up we've got this is
going to be a little bit harder for you
Travis I think I'm sorry from the video
game portal and also video game portal 2
yes it's Chell I like Choa the lady who
doesn't speak at all much paper city 17
where is she I mean I look at I know
what she looks like but there she is
look at her I have popular cosplay as
well yes I actually have arisen pieces
of it do the boots have you done what do
you think Chell would sound like you
know it's weird as I see her with like
an accent mmm like a British accent but
um British accent English accent yeah um
but then she's kind of Sonic Lara Lara
Croft and I don't know if this right I
like the like the idea of her at the
beginning sounding a little more that's
great your yeah one audition one London
feels like true Oliver Twist or
something or something next one off very
difficult character been in dozens and
dozens of games doesn't speak at all
doesn't even have the game named a fact
man this is a competition you'd be
killing it you've already picked up
based on my terrible descriptions Fair
Play thank you thank you
do I go first this one yeah I go for it
yowling links is kind of like from the
South you know I mean look
got a little sprite ears and fingers
gloves weren't green you know Green is
the state color of Missouri that's not
actually true but it is well the only
boys I've Donner kid trunks and
shin-chan so yep I can just see the
sails for Zelda spiking even higher than
that yeah one can not buy that right I
think we did not do anything serious
that's good I like it I'm ready to sue
the night I already took I already took
gel too seriously I'm gonna I gotta fix
it and necks it up is a
anthropomorphised piece of flesh which
jumps around a platform or at very high
speeds this is super meatboy video game
doesn't speak at all
he loves bandage girl and he's made of
me that's all he doesn't actually speak
he just makes dolphin noises sound of
kinda like a dolphin to me
that's disgusting is that the sound of
him talking or just his meat like
flapping Tim laughing I like it guess
what this sound is Wow
you just call those things I think
that's actually really perfect for him
to only communicate in burps and farts
yeah yeah perfect beautiful audition
nailed on and dusted and the last one we
have here of a character a female
character although many people did not
realize she was female character until
the end of the video game Mario Brothers
the big twist we're waiting for after 20
like me to your princess no sorry
from Metroid oh oh
although she's wearing zero suit there I
think yo you can definitely see she's
yeah that's definitely a lady there's a
foreign lady face yeah and her landlords
Laura you're up first
I think she'd be kind of soft-spoken
actually tough but calm yeah like it I
can't even make fun of it looks like a
laser sword
I'd like the bodysuit you can do the
voice of laser sword if you want yeah
the best laser sword around it's pretty
good he's my sidekick laser sword there
you go you could yeah it's like a buddy
comet the news out there's gonna be
zelda thank you so much for playing are
you guys know I've got more stuff well
alright so you just you just arrived
this morning yeah this show today woke
up so early just for you so happy I'm
for Greg Miller well that's you guys had
that there yeah they don't want today
yeah but you might not have realized
that there was a lot of stuff happening
last week here in San Francisco the Game
Developers Conference was on GDC all of
the game developers here literally every
single one of them every one of them
because I had recording sessions last
week there were doppelgangers classic
GDC ruse yep and we chose to be here
instead of then because this is where we
wanted to be yeah
one thing the only thing that was at GDC
last week basically though was virtual
reality there was some regular games but
not a VC Cowboy running around at the
moment love investment and VR is you
know it's actually coming us here we got
PlayStation 4 your Morpheus HTC is all
coming out this year by the way I since
they burped I've got like more burps
stuck in because I like swallowed too
much
that'll be like the like a one episode
like the opening of the chest here's a
new sword
there's no no there's none that's
incredible but virtuoso VR virtual
reality it's like playing video games
except like that yeah it's the future so
the one thing that keeps happening to us
on the press side is that like we write
about VR we do videos before you're over
because it's cool trick it's really cool
I'm like there is a tendency with the
price to be very interested about the
new prank so many games or so like we
want like the new thing so it's
interesting I think for me anyway
because you have this on one side you
got all these are really excited people
at GDC and press people and developers
all talking about this thing and then
you've got this wet farsh in the
realization of the viewers and readers
which is that like they kind of get that
it's you know perhaps probably maybe
going to be this big thing but there's
this kind of lack of interest in it
because you don't have the technology I
think that's what it is I don't think
it's lack of interest I think it's lack
of availability because the masses can't
participate in that beautiful thing that
all of the reviewers are experiencing so
demo is so essential yeah yeah yeah at
e3 last year um I got to play around
with it which one do you know oh and
then the year before that I also played
with the one over at Sony right he's not
fair I got really like motion sick on
know anything they're still working it
out yet it was like a a game where you
were on a thing and you were just like
rolling down a hill but roll yeah Hill
rolled three point four yeah it was it
just made me really pukey the texture I
mean that the demo is so integral to
really getting on board with it I mean I
haven't seen it either and I've heard
rave reviews and then I've heard some
that are a little underwhelming and then
other people say they get motion sick so
I think it's gonna be you know specific
to the person that tries it out but it's
so hard to try and fit people in through
a demo line whether it's a GDC or three
or something like that and I think the
price point also makes people a little
gun-shy I think where it's gonna end up
eventually though is that it's not going
to be just games it's going to be
interactive films it's gonna be you know
it's like all that stuff and ready
player one
like that is the pipe dream to be able
to hop into your favorite movie it's I'm
going home into your favorite location
Walker Enders game
yeah those possibilities I think we'll
make it you know you can't avoid the
possibilities of that kind of tech yeah
it's it's funny that the one demo that
really like sparked my interest about
him more than anything else was one that
actually wasn't really videogames
necessarily was the oculus touch one
where you are in a space and there's
somebody else in another room and you're
basically talking to them and like
throwing objects and we're really in the
virtual space was the other person also
on me yeah they were inside in another
room holding whatever okay that's pretty
freaking cool yeah and it was like
waving hands and like high-fiving in a
virtual space yeah and then after it was
over the gentleman came into the room
and we like we we high-five we were
thinking about it because we'd been
high-fiving in the virtual space but I
thought you know I met this person well
it's crazy
clearly hard and my brain had decided
that I'd met them and it was like I mean
if you can do that across the world
right yeah yeah there was an oculus demo
I think it's so nice Ana Monica where
you put on the headset with the hand
controls whatever they are and you were
inside of a weightless Space Station
that was floating around either Saturn
or the moon or something like that so
you could look out the windows and it
was fully rendered in 1080p or something
like that frame rate was a hundred and
twenty they said because it was a sixty
and sixty in each eye and he said you
would grab onto a part of the station
Space Station and then push yourself
like through the station and that's how
you navigated everything he said after
five or ten minutes he got an incredibly
queasy just because it was working so
well but it became like second nature so
at that source of that sort of immersion
as possible I think it's incredible it's
just I want to experience that
like everybody talks about it and then
you can't do it and it just makes you
jealous and bitter
what's the is a Google glass where they
showed the trailer where you could
literally put a TV screen you know
you're wearing your glasses and a TV
screen on the wall and you can like
absolutely shrink the size Microsoft Sam
yeah it's not Google it's the Microsoft
one once that's it yeah
brain farting at the moment we're smart
halo III was pretty pretty just quite a
small but there you are that's something
that you've had a go of right yeah you
have that sort of yeah and I'm just
really impressed really small yeah it's
like this but the way they set it up at
e3 you know you were in an entire
environment that had been decorated and
then so your little picture fit in
perfectly with the way the environment
had already been done so like that multi
level of gameplay was really cool so
it's interesting right because you're
you're talking about died and you're
you're almost you're basically pitching
it to me right and like what you're
saying is you've never had like all
these people telling you about it is
what yeah so like is it just a case to
worry like do oculus need to just put
trucks outside of like universities and
just have people they couldn't hurt I
really couldn't hurt because I mean word
of mouth is one thing but it's it's kind
of like giving a review for a movie that
you really want to see and until you've
seen it reviews are just crap yeah you
know you don't know you totally disagree
but then a film take it only cost like
12 bucks whereas the end for this is
gonna cost
yeah so do you think do you think yeah
no idea yet no idea I think I'm already
like picturing which room in our house
is gonna be committed to it the walls oh
my gosh but there's so many there's so
many things I want to play already I
mean I was recording just this week on a
on a VR game from valve that's releasing
on Monday I know they premiered it at
the GDC and they said it was it went
over really well and everything and even
the developers we said they hadn't even
got much time like actually in the game
because the the headsets are so limited
right now yeah that's crazy it's gonna
be a long wait before we can do anything
yeah I mean this year's the year where
they all come out but it's probably
going to be another couple years before
we have that like a big mass market like
mindshare right I think the race is on I
mean I've heard rumblings that things
are being worked on but who knows how
close they're guess off to wait and see
yeah yeah yeah if you have any thoughts
about what Virtual Reality head
said you're gonna save up pretty pennies
for your watching this on the Mount
please put your comments in the comment
box below we'll get in there and have a
little chinwag about it loads of VR
stuff we had this old bit unlike UK TV
where they like flip their heads upside
down and draw there was a GameSpot show
which only ever had one episode called
chin wag that was basically that with
two people talking to one my only one
because it was let's just do it right
now can we do yeah we'll just flip the
cameras upside and we'll do no problem
it can work for you can't take it back
are you voice actors are you voice
performers what's like the what's the
word are we what's your word no I say
voice actor somebody asked me what I do
but I don't know I feel like all that's
changing now with so much motion capture
I don't know where that fits into it
right are you doing is his motion
capture becoming more and more part of
every gig yeah definitely yeah we say
voice actors I think just so that we can
cut down on the conversation time you
say actors people like what have I seen
you in animated shows you've been in
you'll see me as when I interact your
projects you've been in but motion
capture showing up and pretty much all
of the Triple A titles not really change
the work at all because it definitely
changes the work yeah it just it creates
more time in the development process
with us like when we did second son it
was really one of the first times that
we were involved so early on in the game
you know as a voice actor so much of the
game is made and then we come in and
we're the cherry on top of all of the
substance that's been worked on for
months yeah with with motion capture you
come in so early because it takes so
long to get all the input and everything
um we get to really have more say and
who the characters become and
more influence in the story and
everything that's more satisfying
interest as performers to be or I mean
the creative process is such a you know
such a precious thing you get to go in
and speak with the writing team and
they're asking your input and maybe
they're looking for some inspiration
here they're maybe they use it maybe
they don't but you just feel like you're
more invested it means more to you and
you really get to know the studio's all
the all the people that make it work and
you know when you're in a recording
booth very rarely do you get to meet all
of the animators and everything behind
it and it's so nice to get to go to the
studio and see see everything that goes
into and there's so much more than you
would ever expect yeah it's all it's
always a great experience because you're
we are as excited to see the QA
department the animators the writers and
lighting specialists all those people
and then they are equally excited to
meet the people that they've been
staring at for you know six months
probably cursing it sometimes well their
families are at home wondering where
they are so stuck on my chair and I was
like totally awkwardly like she gave me
actually you just trapped me first what
was the first guy wrong show I was
earlier I don't have any um what was the
how do you get into that you probably
answer this question about a thousand
one times but like how is it presumably
now once you're in here you're finding
gigs a lot easier because you're making
those connections and you have this like
palette of work that you've been working
on have but hey it must be quite
difficult to actually break in the first
place the very first gig you get yeah
incredibly hard but everybody finds it
in a different way you know
when when we both started we were in
Texas and Funimation was the very first
place we ever worked which was um you
know anime and my first gig was Dragon
Ball Z hmm and I only found it I only
got the audition because I was in a play
and somebody there saw me and you know
they recommended me for the show and so
I got to go in and legend for Dragon
Ball Z but you can't just call up a
studio you can't just like see what's
happening so I it's so hard just to hear
the auditions are coming up and then be
able to get your foot in the door there
right yeah I mean your entire life has
been basically taken that way because of
a chance encounter essentially yeah it's
one play that I did created this entire
world of acting
me that I never even realized existed
did you have any visible to yourself was
it something you always wanted to do or
like how does it come about
I didn't plan for it at all I you know I
went to college to study theater and
performance arts and that was that was
pretty much it I didn't know if that was
gonna be film or TV right you know those
are like the big dreams but I was still
in Fort Worth Texas at the time and when
Funimation came along I was a fan of
Dragon Ball Z for years before I even
realized that she was in the show so
when I knew that she was a character I
was like I know what that character
sounds like that doesn't sound anything
like Laura how that's impossible and you
listen again and instantly that
curiosity of this show that I was such a
fan of who's done so close I founded her
and pretty much everybody else that I
knew that worked there for months and
years and you know finally got an
audition didn't blow it didn't suck hmm
and and it just kind of went out from
there but and never had any intention of
like being a video game voice actor or
animation voice actor and it was only
after you first consider her after I
first considered like all these animes
are things that we can work in you know
being such a cartoon fan growing up
loving Thundercats loving Silverhawks
loving Voltron I was like you know to me
as kids those were just those characters
lived by themselves they weren't real
people Yeah right always divided those I
didn't want to know anything about them
it's crazy yeah I didn't even know like
I still even in Dallas for the eight
years that I was a voice actor I was
doing a lot of other on camera and I
thought that's still the direction I was
gonna go voice acting was this fun thing
I got to do on the south it's kind of
yeah but it still didn't pay that much
and it was just fun to do and and then
after I moved out to California the
whole world opened up because there's
just so much more you know available out
here then there was back in Texas and
that's when I realized this this side of
things can actually be a career that's
crazy and awesome and freeing now the
weird thing about the acting business
which I'm sure has been said before mine
there's no like set path there's no
ladder to my time you know people asked
like can I go get voice acting training
somewhere yeah sure and you know does it
help if I do theater or if I go take
workshops yeah you know but nothing's
ever yes or no it's just sometimes it's
a complete accident sometimes it's
kismet sometimes people come at it from
stand-up some people come from on-camera
work some people come from a theatre
production people are athletes some
people are comedians some people I mean
it just you know it's just a different
number of things and we just normally
tell people like if it's something that
you really want to do when you think you
have a talent in it then just pursue it
relentlessly and whatever will happen
will happen as a lifestyle is it
something I mean you guys have a couple
as well and so is it is it less
demanding in some ways than on-camera
work because it's a bit more like like
the project sure that one because I I
don't know anyone who works as an actor
I have friends who work in lighting and
stuff in high when the days seem to drag
on forever so you're constantly on call
for like yes that doesn't happen in
voice actor which is in voice acting
which is really nice you usually have a
set schedule right but there's a
trade-off yeah yeah whereas like our
days might be shorter the use of your
immediate visceral imagination is far
higher because if you're in motion
capture you're in a blank room with no
set certainly no effects no makeup no
lighting it is just your old school
theater imagination and hopefully that's
a great like matching up with what the
performer in your space is also
imagining this block of styrofoam is now
your gun no usually your weapons are
actually labeled like weapons but
everything else is just a you know a
prop that doesn't this is it hat it's
now a hat and it's your hat yeah you
quickly see who has the ability to
really like you know conform and warp
their imaginations and really has the
ability to play and I mean it's it's and
it's very expensive each minute of
recording in a space like that probably
a lot of pressure for you guys in that
respect as well right yeah there is if
you if you're out of water and you're
uncomfortable it'll be very clear very
quickly yeah but I think that old-school
theater training really helps in
situations like that yeah I heard Matt
saying that earlier
it's very true what is it what do you
enjoy about it the most about motion
caps first no just absence in fact
performing about voice acting about okay
oh I just love that you can be anything
that you can imagine you know when when
I was doing more on camera you're you're
stuck and a lot of times you walk into
the room and they've decided whether or
not you're cast before you ever even say
a word because your hair is too dark or
your chest is too small or your nose is
too big or whatever and with voice
acting they don't see you most of the
time you record from home or from your
up from your studio and your agency or
whatever and they just listen to the
sound and you know that if you're
getting a callback or if you're getting
cast it's because of your performance
it's because of what you did which is
really amazing and you own it wholly yes
yeah we get to play every single day
when we're like some of the luckiest
people because it's just our
imaginations you know getting worked if
there's anybody that's like annoyed with
work about more complaining going to
work that they have no idea what they're
talking about we're working in some of
the coolest universes you know whether
it's comics or you know get game
franchises or anything like that I mean
these are things that we grew up loving
as we were kids and just to be able to
be a part of that and have some sort of
our influence I'm sort of you know our
take our opinion on a character or a
storyline be implemented and something
that's being produced that's it's just
crazy satisfying for nerds and it's
funny I guess the sort of the last one I
want to touch on is kind of what you
were saying earlier which is very
interesting which is that like I'm in
the same situation where when I found it
who like the voice of bender was like
realizing hey the voice of Marcus Fenix
is like I don't really want to know that
whereas like in movies there's this
propensity to be attracted towards the
performer and then watch the movie
wholly because of them right your guys's
work it's almost like people don't want
to know we get that fine line it's a
fine line that's being made now because
a lot of times things are starting to
take likeness based on boys so you know
we're working on multiple projects that
have actually taken our face and put it
in the game and then you're like huh I
mean that's really cool I love that I
look like a superhero you know and I
could shoot lasers out of my hands
at the same time that that ambiguity is
is
in voice acting so how many roles do you
take where they can see your face and do
you want to back away from it right it's
a hard it's a hard decision yeah voice
actors that have that chameleon ability
the ability to have several you know
separate voices with separate
personalities is attached right you
can't see their face you wouldn't know I
mean they're just blue chip type actors
yeah yeah so it's it's an interesting
thing well we get to the point where the
technology well I guess we probably are
there already where you can basically be
like Andy Serkis right and just like oh
yeah have you know be go be Godzilla and
be Smeagol and not one of the greatest
mocap actors out there right now is a
guy named TJ storm that works on a ton
of his real martial arts Hall of Fame it
might even be like the karate or
technique he's so cool any so he's huge
and he's got these long braids and he's
just the coolest and he so Zen you know
so Center but he did the monk he's a
monk great yeah it is a nice drunk the
mocha for guns illa he did the mocap for
Colossus in the X and Deadpool he was he
was in knack with us and he played knack
so he was giant nag but he was little
knack in his body stance when he would
change and become big nak it's just so
amazing to see the the change in bodies
it's amazing the art movement that's the
next one he'll be a half length time
today last note on this what video games
you guys playing at the moment that we
can tell you about wait they were
playing or laying Oh play I know I can't
find out why your bin I'm still I am
still deep in fallout world oh cool
although I'm not romancing mat sorry man
I except from a dog me neither
right get that Park yeah I like being
solo man roller
man I am in the division now our free
time is almost nil so I just made it
over to Manhattan which is basically
just like leaving the tutorial so I had
a huge amount of time to hop in but I go
I hop in and turn my brain off so I'm at
GTA guy and a nice Call of Duty 3 or
black ops 3 and you know you
GTA online oh yeah that's great yeah
like 79 just run in cause havoc for two
hours he's a troll Bernie he's a
horrible horrible person I've got a
fighter jet and you're driving around
town just I love it if there was ever a
game for thought it was GTA oh thank you
both so much for coming and really
appreciated Mercia and Matthew as well
thank you so much
I thank you so much to everyone who's
been watching today's show I'm to the
intrepid Eric Tay and Mary case you've
been running all these live streams and
they're not done yet
we're not done yeah we got more Dark
Souls 3 we have an exclusive stream
kicking off right here on twitch.tv
forward slash GameSpot on on gamespot
calm so if you're a fan of games that
kick your ass make sure you stick around
for that one I not sure if it's - Eric
do you know if it's starting at three
o'clock or half three or are we clap for
o'clock good I know the voice of God
made Kish there they deserved 20 minutes
off before we started off again and
thank you so much for watching the lobby
if you're listening to Lobby make sure
to review rate us on iTunes we really
appreciate your time and we'll see you
same time 2 p.m. Pacific right here on
GameSpot calm Dark Souls 3 or 4 o'clock
see you then
like the Doppler